Wow. Niemals zu früh vor der Panflöte reinkommen. Niemals vor der Panflöte reinkommen. Man merkt es Panflötenspielern an, wenn sie gleich Panflöte spielen. Sie holen einen tiefen Luftzug und dann gehst du rein mit Puppensicherheit. Dankeschön an alle, dass die da sind. Das geht so nicht. Stefan. Ich denke, wenn wir immer vor den Pan-Flötenspielern reinkommen. Ja, wenn dann komplett alles unterbringen, die Message vor der Pan-Flöte, aber nie rein in die Pan-Flöte. Wow! Moritz! Erstmal diese Stimme war wunderschön. Das war wirklich schön, der Text war wunderschön.
Und Shakira war im Raum mit uns, Gott hab sie selig, sie ist dabei, schön, dass sie da ist, sie läutet ja normalerweise den Sonne ein, sie fackelt den Sommer ein, ja, sie nimmt die grosse Fackel und zündet das grosse Fackelfeuer an. Und dann Shakira, nicht zu wenigstens mit Shark-Ira, das war ein Hai in einem Zoo Zoo World in Alabama, der leider fünf Menschen das Leben genommen hat. Und sich dann selbst die Pulse ernten. Suizid der Hai, der Einzug. Selbst in den Schwanz gebissen und sich dann selbst aufgefressen. Es gibt nicht viele Tiere, die zum Suizid fähig sind, der Hai leider in der Tat. Leider in der Tat auch sehr gewillt, das Tun und andere mit sich zu reissen.
Moritz, danke, dass du mit uns hier die Folge begonnen hast. Vielen, vielen Dank. Wir sind mittlerweile im Sommer angekommen, die T-Shirts sind an, wir sind auf der Picknickdecke unterwegs, die Hummeln, die Wespen, die Bienen, sie alle umschwirren uns fröhlich und es ist heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß. Die verdammten Hornissen! Ich habe ein T-Shirt an in der Farbe, ja, Baby Blue Glacier, Glacier Blue. Baby Blue, es ist so ein bisschen Hautausschlagblau, erinnert mich an die damalige Zeit, als ich einen Blaualgenausschlag bekommen habe, schön damals in Ebersberg am Klostersee, der dann lange, lange gesperrt wurde, weil ich einen Ausschlag bekommen habe. Und ich finde es immer faszinierend, dass die, genau, die Bepflanzung hieß Blaualge und mein Ausschlag war auch blau. Und bis heute frage ich mich, ob es da Zusammenhang gibt, heissen die Blaualgen wegen des blauen Ausschlags oder sind die blau und verursachen auch eine blaue Krankheit, was ich zu passen fände, als dass die Welt nicht von einem Schöpfer gemacht wurde. Das war Florentins, muss man rückblickend sagen, gescheiterte Origin-Story zum Algenman, also hättest du werden können, der Blaualgenman. Richtig, ich war nur schwach und es hat gejuckt. Genau, es ist schwach gejuckt und du warst ein bisschen sensibler als sonst für Geräusche. Allerdeck. Und es ist mehr Hunger, aber es ist sehr langweilig für alle und auch nervig für alle um mich herum. Es ist super langweilig. Eine Klassenkameradin von mir wurde von einem Karpfen gebissen. Die ist als Karp-Lady bis heute aktiv. Sie kann unter Wasser atmen, sie kann sehr flach sich auf den Boden legen und sie kann zappeln wie keine zweite. Das ist alles, weil ein kleiner Karpfen erweiterten Suizid beginnen wollte. Richtig. Nein, aber ich hatte nur die Blaualgenallergie und so ungefähr sah ich dann auch aus mit Oberkörperfrei. So siehst du heute aus mit deinem ausschlagfarbenen T-Shirt. Das, was mir daran gefällt, ich habe gelernt, ich soll Softfarben tragen, gedeckte Farben, die sich ein bisschen zurücknehmen, weil ich sehr leicht, ich finde selbst meine Haut ist so sensibel, dass zu krasse Farben sie bereits nahezu unsichtbar machen. Ja und natürlich, dein harter Charakter muss kontrastiert werden, sanfte Farben, Lavendeltöne, eisenharten Charakter irgendwie zu kontrastieren. Mein Charakter ist so fucking hart, dass die Farben, die müssen nicht entspannen, sonst geht niemand mehr auf mich zu. Ich bin auch, ich bin willig, man denkt ja darüber nach, über faschistische, autoritäre Systeme und ich denke mir immer, ich würde so buckeln, sofort ab der ersten Sekunde. Ich knick ein, ich bin sofort weg, ich freue mich immer, wenn ich was richtig mache. Ich bin heute an einem Polizeirevier vorbeigelaufen und da stehen ja immer dann so Kampagnen, Poster, was man machen soll und wie man sich verhalten soll und da war ein Claim, der mir sehr gut gefallen hat. Schnell dich einfach, leg dich auf den Boden, er gibt dich und leg dich auf den Boden. Er gibt dich auf den Boden, gehorche dem Gesetz und leide unter unserer Knute. Und dann habe ich noch ein viertes Poster gesehen mit einem, finde ich, sehr eingängigen Spruch, besser ohne Messer. Und die Botschaft war im Grunde, hab kein Messer. Hab einfach kein Messer. Das gefällt mir ja generell an der Diskussion, die gerade herrscht, wenn Leute mit Autos in Menschenmengen fahren und dann geht natürlich die Waffe, den Leuten wegzunehmen. Autos werden aber nicht verboten, dann werden überall die Dinger hochgefahren in den Fusswerkzeugen. Das muss man sichern. Die Pöllerindustrie boomt, muss man auch sagen. Die gehen auch hoch. Oh, kommen wir gleich dazu. Interessiert die ganze Klasse. Aber dann, wenn dann Messermenschen kommen und mit Messer Leute attackieren, dann die Diskussion wird ja trotzdem geführt. Lange Messer den Leuten wegnehmen. Wie lang darf das Messer sein, die Klinge, wie viele Klingen pro Messer? Genau, ich sehe mich bei Ohne Messer läuft es besser oder wie das Mischmessige. Ja, besser ohne Messer. Besser ohne Messer. Ich sehe mich in der Küche stehen mit einem grossen Fragezeichen. Mit meinem Hammer und ich hämmer mir die Butter aufs Brot, weil ich denke, noch ist der Hammer erlaubt, noch wurde er mir nicht entrissen. Ja, aber was denn dann? Ich nutze das gerne noch. Es ist wie so Erziehungsberechtigte, die uns dann die Messer wegnehmen und uns so Plastikmesser geben. Ja, und alles halt nur noch Löffel. Im Grunde alles nur noch Löffel. So weiche Sachen. Und ich habe dieses Poster gesehen und ich hatte wirklich dieses innerliche Wohlgefühl der Pflichterfüllung und habe gesagt, ja, ich habe kein Messer an mir. Ich habe kein Messer dabei, nichts dabei. Du wolltest aber, dass sie dich untersuchen, du wolltest ein bisschen, dass sie dich untersuchen, so abklopfen und kein Messer finden. Und dann sagen, ui, toi, toi, toi und knarre. Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey anfällig für autoritäre Gesetze und Knoten, ich würde sofort buckeln wahrscheinlich. Ich würde mich freuen, dass ich buckel. Du würdest buckeln, ich würde fliehen. Das habe ich jetzt immer mehr gecheckt. Okay. An mir, ich glaube, ich wäre so typisch... Hast du eine Fluchtroute schon? Hast du den Rattenweg schon? Exil, im Zweifelsüden. Süden, Elba. Ich konnotiere, genau. Direkt Exil, soll ganz nett sein. Wo wurde noch mal Napoleon hin ins Exil geschickt? Elba. Elba. Elba. Ich denke, also Fluchtinstinkt nach Süden irgendwie oder ganz in den Norden. In eine der Richtungen muss er. Ja, aber da darfst du jetzt auch nicht so oft umdrehen. Du wärst dann, glaube ich, jemand auf der Flucht der, nee, komm, doch Norwegen. Hin und her und am Ende bist du doch nur hier raus. Norwegen hat ja auch Vorteile und im Sommer ja auch wahnsinnig schön, dann denke ich mir, dann wird es da zu kalt im Winter und dann glaube ich wieder durch Deutschland und werde festgenommen. Aber doch, mein Instinkt ist tatsächlich eher dann raus. Und dann kann ich ja deine Karriere, deine Stellkarriere vom sicheren Exilort beobachten. Ich puckel, ich bin direkt dabei und ich würde dich auch sofort denunzieren. Also sofort, vielleicht kann ich dich jetzt schon denunzieren. Einfach stopp, bevor die Machtergreifung stattfindet, würde ich dich jetzt schon denunzieren. Da ist er, da läuft er in dem babyblauen T-Shirt, da ist er, der läuft er. Unschwel zu erkennen, wegen meiner Farbanalyse, neuerdings, ich wäre untergegangen. Stich's gut raus. An dem Meer aus schwarzen und weissen und grauen Sachen, gehe ich jetzt mit meinem Mauve und Lavender und Taub hier falle ich auf. Für alle, die diese Folge als erste ausgewählt haben, um in den Pufo-Kosmos einzusteigen, grosse Verwirrung, Stefan Tietz hat eine Farbanalyse gemacht bei Anoushka Rees. Und anscheinend haben einige Hörerinnen und Hörer oder vor allem Hörer dieser Idee gefolgt, denn einige haben auch diesen Farbtest gemacht und auf Reddit hat jemand gepostet, der eine Nachricht von ihr gescreenshotet hat mit, hey, ich kriege gerade einen grossen Zulauf von männlichen Kunden, wie kommt das denn? Und anscheinend bist du dafür verantwortlich, dass viele männliche Hörer jetzt eine Farbenanalyse machen und besser aussehen in diesem Sommer. Danke. Sie hat auch mir geschrieben und richtet liebe Grüße auch an dich aus und grüsst uns und hat uns gesagt. Passiv aggressive Grüße im Sinne von du Fettsack solltest du zumindest mal was ordentliches anziehen, um nicht so scheiße auszusehen oder eher freundlich. Der falsch angezogene, blasse Junge soll doch mal bitte eine Analyse machen. Nee, sie hat gesagt, sie freut sich sehr auf seine Fotos und würde sich freuen, bei einer Farbanalyse zu machen. Die Frau ist auch erst zufrieden, wenn jeder einzelne Mensch sich richtig anzieht auf dieser Welt die richtigen Farben hat. Ich sag, dass es grössenwahn, das ist der autoritäre Faschismus, von dem wir uns hüten müssen. Faschisten sind in der Regel gut angezogen und deswegen sollten wir uns auf die Hut nehmen. Wobei dieses Hugo Boss, dieses stramme SS-Hugo Boss-Schwarz hat den meisten nicht gestanden. Muss man sagen. Leider auch. Für sich genommen keine Notes, no notes. Mein Führer, eine Frage noch zu den Uniformen. Die sind super, wie sie sind. Hugo hat das Perfekt designt, diewarz, die sind schnittig. Heil Hugo, nichts gegen Hugo, der hat das ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz toll gemacht. Jetzt ist allerdings leider gerade meine Farbanalyse reingekommen und ich natürlich als Reichsmarschall Göring würde natürlich gerne eher in so ein Blassgelb gehen. Also wie gesagt, die Analyse kam und würde jetzt gar nicht so zu diesem Schwarz passen. Ja, aber wir können ja bei jedem auf die Farbanalyse warten. Und dann können die rumlaufen wie ein Zirkus. Der eine blau, der andere mauve. Ja gut, wir können ja zumindest zwei, drei. Der andere Gletscher blau, der andere sage green. Wir können ja zwei, drei verschiedene Varianten anbieten, einfach mal so ein paar grobe abzubilden. Also das vielleicht, klar, Schwarz bleibt erstmal, das ist ja wunderbar. Aber schwarz steht wo Drew Winters, mir, mein Führer, also bei aller Lieben. Ich habe die so ausgewählt farblich, dass die nur mir gut stehen. Aber der Führer muss vor allem erstmal in erster Linie, als der... Ich würde alles tun, damit sie gut dastehen. Ich habe Ihnen zu dem Bart geraten. Gut, dann tragen Sie Ihre schwarze … Der Bart Fax. Okay, der Bart Fax. Der Bart ist gut. Der Bart ist richtig gut. Wir haben alles richtig gemacht. Wir haben alles richtig gemacht. Wir waren nur für mich jetzt auch mal kurz an mich gedacht. Sie haben auch schön gemacht. So was Maisfarbenes, so ein herbes Sonnenbrandgelb. ein bisschen in die ecke dachte ich vielleicht jetzt oder so sie sind grau grau und kaki können wir machen vielleicht sie glasgelb ok einzige blasgelb ok danke weil sie gesagt haben dass fackst. Der Bart wirklich, der macht keinen langen Prozess. Na komm, komm, danke, abgetreten. Achso, weggetreten, abtreten, ausdrücken. Ich muss ausdrücken. In tausend Jahren eine Umarmung vielleicht mal? Nein, nur für ein Bon, vielleicht morgen. Deswegen tausendjähriges Reich. Ja, sie schieben auf, sie schieben viel auf. Jetzt sind wir wieder bei Hitler gelandet. Vielen Dank an Moritz für das Intro, für die Pahnflöte, extra Pahnflöte gelernt, muss man ja auch mal sagen, Pahn heisst ja alles, also das ist die Allesflöte, was ein Versprechen ist, der Name von der, also von diesem sehr beschränkten, tonal beschränkten Instrument Pahnflöte, ja auch fucking ballsy. Ja, vor allem man kann die Töne einfach abzählen an den Röhrchen. Also es ist nicht so wie bei einer Trompeto, man denkt, okay, drei Knöpfe, aber viel mehr Töne, wie geht das, Hexerei? Aber bei der Panflöte ist relativ offen. Trompeten verbrennen jetzt. Trompeto, du drückst drauf. Ja, genau. Das ist schwierig. Zurück, um Klammer zuzumachen, vielen Dank an Moritz für das Intro, ganz, ganz toll, Panflöte nochmal gemacht.
Die ganzen Leute, ich finde es toll, Männer wollen sich jetzt auch. Es war, ich glaube, Farbanalyse und ich glaube auch, dass ich damals, als ich die Farbanalyse gemacht hatte, vor irgendwie wahrscheinlich einer der ersten, oder nicht einer der ersten Männer, aber zu den wenigen Männern gehört habe, die das gemacht haben. Ich freue mich, ich mache mich ein bisschen stolz, dass sich jeder davon erzählt hat und Leute machen es auch. Jetzt, weil das ist so ein bisschen weiblich konnotiertes Feld. Ich finde gut, wir brechen das auf, wir machen das für alle klar und offen, so wie es sein muss. Männer, zieht euch schön an, sucht euch schöne Farben aus und macht eine Farbenanlösung. Ich finde das toll. Und sie hat mir auch geschrieben, sie hat sich gewundert, warum ganz viele deutsche Männer plötzlich die Farbenanlösung bei ihr machen wollen. Ich glaube, es war vorher ein sehr international weibliches Feld und jetzt war es die deutschen Männer wollen stramm schick aussehen. Ja, ich wittere da fast schon wieder so ein T-Reddit-Ding, dass wir das irgendwie dann doch annektieren, so aus Versehen. Hubsala. Dass wir Hubsala mal wieder irgendeine Invasion vorbereiten und die irgendwann sagt, ey, please no analysis from outside Germany. Und wir plötzlich, oh, scheinbar haben wir doch noch wieder was erobert. Mann, es ist aber auch so leicht, Leute, mein Gott, können die Franzosen, es ist so leicht einfach, am Ende macht man es dann nebenbei, ne? Ja, warst du eigentlich aus dem T-Reddit geworden? T-Reddit geht es gut, ich krieg ab und zu mal wieder Vorschläge, es gibt, es soll eine Kontrarevolution geben, es gibt einige T-Shirt-Fans. Sind wir gewappnet? Also um es kurz einzuführen, falls alle jetzt die Pufo-Geschichte LK nicht haben oder da nur vier Punkte oder weniger haben. Es gab mal das Reddit TEE für T-Shirts. Wir haben das einfach gewaltsam erobert und bereinigt. Und mittlerweile steht das Reddit TEE für den deutschen Tee, das leckere Heißgetränk. Tegenuss. Und es gibt aber Kontrarevolutionäre, die jetzt im Untergrund wieder versuchen, das dem T-Shirt anzubringen, also wieder ein paar T-Shirt-Posts zu posten, die werden natürlich im Keim erstickt. Generell finde ich aber, unabhängig von allen zurechtformulierten faschistoiden Vorwürfen gegen uns, dass wir das ganze gewaltsam anaktiert haben, den Schuh müssen wir uns anziehen. Die Vorstelle, naja, müssen wir? Ah, nicht? Nee, eigentlich nicht. Okay, wir hätten uns vielleicht vorher nochmal abbrechen sollen. Wir hätten gesagt, dass wir den Schuh abstreiten. Wir ziehen den Schuh nicht ab, weil es zu groß ist. Wir machen die Schnürsenkel auf und schauen, was passiert. Genau. Wir machen die Schnürsenkel auf und reden so schnell. Wir probieren den Schuh mal an. Na, man kann den mal anprobieren. Und dann kommt so eine Mitarbeiterin und packt den Daumen drauf und wir sagen, was sie hören will. Ja, und dann sagt die Mitarbeiter, laufen Sie mal ein Stück und du läufst dann wie so ein Storch mit einem Bein zu lang und denkst dir, was soll mir das bringen, ich kann nicht laufen, weil ich nur einen Schuh anhab. Ja, und ich will diese Rutsche, diese Holzrutsche runterrutschen. Will die hochrennen und runterrutschen? Und ich will wissen, warum es die ausschließlich in Schuhläden gibt, den schlechtesten Laden für Holzrutschen. Richtig, muss man auch sagen, allerdings es gab am Münchner Stachus, am O-Blätter, da gab es immer, da gab es die Holzrutsche. Ach, diese Münchner Kampfbegriffe. Na, was ist das, das ist ja möglich, was ist das, mir ist das, mir, beim O-Blätter am Stachus, da gab es schön die Holzrutsche. Über oder unter der Isar, so, lass es mich wissen. Da gab es eine Holzrutsche und da bin ich als Kind immer gerutscht und das ist ein Spielwarenladen. Das heißt, du hast als Kind eh schon genug zu tun, aber es wird trotzdem noch gerutscht und jetzt vor vielen, vielen Jahren war ich da mal und die Rutsche war gesperrt. Und da waren lauter Fussbälle in der Rutsche und dann habe ich auch mich erkundigt, wie, was ist denn, warum kann man nicht rutschen und dann war war auch der Blick ganz trüb mit so, na ja, da gab es einen Vorfall. Bis heute habe ich mich nicht getraut zu googeln, ob es da irgendwas gibt. Da gab es einen Vorfall. Ja, Oblätter am Stachus, ein Vorfall. Ich weiß nicht, ob, weil es ist einfach eine gerade Rutsche. Ich weiß weder wie man Oblätter noch wie man Stachus schreibt, aber ich weiß nicht, wie man Mühe war. Stefan Tietze nimmt sich das Fals an. München, Rutsche,ülwagen lang. Stefan Tietze nimmt sich das Pfalz an. Mündchen, Rutsche, Vorwand, Stefan Tietze, Unbekannt, das sprüht Hagenkreuz auf Spielplatz Rutsche.
Wirklich unbekannt, Pasing, das Recht auf Spielen.
Wie unbekannt, das ist jetzt aber wirklich ein Trefferradius von vielen Kilometern.
Nein, das glaubst du nicht.
Schluss nach fast 200 Jahren. Obletter am Stachus macht zu. Nein! 2021! 21? Aufgrund eines Vorfalls mit der Rutsche muss das Spielwarengeschäft am Stachus in gut einem Jahr schliessen. Der Inhaber einer Drogeriemarktkette will den Mietvertrag nicht verlängern. Warum, bleibt unklar. What? Es ist der Schlusspunkt einer wechselvollen Firmenhistorie. Allerdings, das kann man wohl oder übel sagen. Wollen wir rein? Wollen wir tief rein? Der rote Schriftzug über der Tür sieht noch so aus wie früher. Ich weiss, da habe ich so Playmobil gekauft. Steht dort in runden roten Buchstaben, flankiert von zwei Schaukelpferden. Den Schriftzug kannte in München lange jedes Kind. Ja, und dann ging es die Reppe runter, das war ja zweistöckig. Florentin Will, in Klammern 34. Zitat, hol ein Zitat raus. Ja, da war ich früher immer, also das war immer herrlich, war jetzt nicht so gut wie der Karstadt, aber so ein paar Figuren und ein paar Hörspiele habe ich da immer mitgenommen. Es hat Zeiten gegeben, da liess das traditionsreiche Münchner Spielwarengeschäft einen Katalog drucken, bis zu 100 Seiten dick und mit einer Auflage von 1,2 Millionen Exemplaren. What? Wie viele Kinder gibt's? Nur kleine Randnotiz. 1,2? Man braucht, um auf die Spiegel-Bestsellerliste zu kommen, glaube ich 20.000 Bücher verkauft. Ja, ja, ja, liebe Grösse an der Stelle. Okay. 1,2. Der wurde nur als Stammkunden verschickt und in Münchner Briefkästen gestopft, auf das die Kleinen beim Blättern ins Träumen gerieten. Im Laden dann am Stachus gab es das alles zum Anfassen, von der Puppe bis zu Ritterburg, vom Klinik-Rieterspiel bis zur Rasse, vom Teddybär bis zur Actionfigur. Zwei Etagen, 1500 Quadratmeter nebenbei noch das grösste Kinderbuchabteilung in Deutschland und ins Untergeschoss konnte man rutschen. Aber das ist ja mal so ein Curveball-Satz, oder? Er wurde auserwählten Stammkunden gegeben und in Münchner Briefkästen gestopft. Und unwilligen Leuten in den Briefkästen gestopft. Er wurde erlesene Stammkundenden ausgehändigt und in Briefkästen gestopft. Ganz fantastisch. So, wir gehen ein bisschen da unten. Wir rutschen, ja, was ist passiert? Was mich interessiert, ist die Filmhistorie, weil die reicht bis ins Jahr 1925 zurück. Und ich finde das ja mega spannend. Nach Kaut Bullinger und Sport Münzinger ist Oblätter Tag mit dem Mobil das nächste Münchner Traditionsaus. Das schliesst alle geschlossen. Denn auch wenn in diesem Fall fraglich ist, die Filmtradition wirklich noch in Oblätter steckt, reicht diehistorien doch weit zurück bis ins Jahr 1825. Es war das Jahr, in dem König Ludwig der
Erste den bayerischen Thron bestieg. Die Stadt wuchs die Glyphothek, Glyptothek, was ist das?
Die Glyptothek? Weißt du, was das ist? Die Ludwigstrasse waren Baustellen, da kam Joseph
Obleter aus Südtirol in die Stadt, im Handgepäck, handgeschnitzte Holzfiguren und eröffneten
Gesteck am Schraunenplatz. Schön. Ja, sehr, sehr schön. Wirklich schöner Laden. So, was ist mit den Nazis, das überspringen wir jetzt mal. Da habe ich aber letztendlich, dieses Jahr habe ich noch ein Geschenk gekauft für meinen Neffen. Nee, es hat drei Jahre zu. Und mal wieder fällt das Lügengebäude Florentinville in sich zusammen. Was habe ich denn da gemacht?
Das kann wirklich nicht sein. Aber diese Rutschen sind, glaube ich, einfach Genickbrecher. Also da wirst du einfach. Aber was ich so spannend finde bei diesen Geschäften, diesen Schuhgeschäften, die ich meine, wo die vor allem drin waren, also bei mir, wo ich herkomme im Ruhrgebiet, da waren die nur in so Schuhgeschäften, so Kinder-Schuhgeschäften. Ja, absolut, ja. Und dann ist man da rein, dann hat man den Schuh anprobiert, dann kam die Mitarbeiterin, hat den Daumen vorne angelegt, um zu gucken, wo der Daumensee ist, um dann immer es so zu verkaufen, dass das schon der richtige Schuh ist. Genau, entweder, ah, du hast noch genug Platz, oder, ah, der sitzt fest.
Ah, der dehnt sich aus, also, was ich auch noch finde, der gibt noch nach, keine Angst, der gibt noch nach,
ah, du hast noch genug Platz, oder, ah, der ist perfekt.
Aber in keinem Fall habe ich dann nach dem Daumentest gehört bekommen so,
oh, oh, fuck, zieh den sofort wieder aus, oh, shit, der ist komplett falsch.
Nicht, es geht einfach nur darum, das Ergebnis zu interpretieren, was ich wirklich eine schöne Aufgabe finde, die man so einfach verlernen muss. Als würde man zu Ollivanders gehen, würde einen Zauberstab ausprobieren, auswutscheln und wedeln, dann fliegt was in die Luft und er sagt, ah ja, da hast du ja viel Potenzial mit. Genau. Und wenn gar nichts passiert, na, an dem kannst du noch wachsen. Ja, genau. Es ist immer ein richtiges Ergebnis. Der Schuh sucht sich wie so oft den Träger aus. Aber Kinder sind auch komplett bescheuert, wenn es ums Rutschen geht. Also die sind wirklich, also absolute Selbstzerstörungstrieb, wenn es ums Rutschen geht. Ich habe ja Zivil gemacht mit Kindern und da war man dann auch irgendwie unterwegs mit der ganzen Gruppe Spielplatz. Und dann direkt neuer Spielplatz, da waren die Kinder noch nie, ja, irgendwie haben wir so einen Ausflug gemacht und ein Mädchen geht zur Rutsche, rutscht, kopfüber auf dem Rücken, war der erste Rutsch und es war nicht, ah, ich kenne die Rutsche, ich rutsche ein paar Mal runter, ich beisse es ein bisschen auf, sondern der erste unbekannte Rutsche auf dem Rücken, kopfüber und ich sofort hingesprintet, aber wirklich direkt, ah, daran kann ich mir wehtun, wie kann ich mir maximal wehtun? Einfach direkt rein, Haare fest, das ist ja auch, diese Rutschen sind ja teilweise extrem rau und dann irgendwie Haare, Kopf überdehnt, komplette Katastrophe. Ich weiss nicht, was bei dir ist, aber ich habe als Kind immer eine wahnsinnige Angst vor sowas gehabt. Ich bin gerutscht, klar, ich habe dabei gejubelt, gelacht, haha, Laches falten, alles fake.
Alles fake.
Innerlich hast du geschrien.
Innerlich habe ich gedacht, hast du geschrien, gekauert.
Ich habe mich immer gefreut, ist wie am Skifahren ein bisschen bei mir.
Ich mache dann da mit und mache, glaube ich, den Anschein, als ob ich dabei bin, jejeje,
aber nach jeder Abfahrt danke ich Gott, dass ich noch lebe. Und hoffe, dass der Lift ausfällt. Genau, also und dann, wann gehen wir ja endlich Mittag machen. Und das ist genauso bei Rutschen damals auch schon gewesen oder bei so Schwimmbadbesuchen, dass ich mich immer bekreuzigt habe, wenn ich unten angekommen bin, heile. Weil warum soll man, ich habe es nie verstanden, Spaß daraus zu aus maximal hoher Höhe. Genau, die maximale Todesangst. Mit maximaler Geschwindigkeit herunterzurutschen. Und ähnlich kriege ich dann, es sind furchtbare Videos, die mir gerade angezeigt werden, bei den TikToks dieser Welt, von so Bungee-Seilen, die reissen. Da haben wir alle überlebt. Sagt es jetzt, steht dann unten immer drin. Aber dann für mich das Konzept Bungie nicht. Wenn das sei reisst und man trotzdem überlebt, dann ist das Quatsch. Die Betroffene hat überlebt, das ist so meine Erlaubnis, herzhaft zu lachen über ein Video. Aber wie? Also ähm, 200 Meter sind für einen Menschen ticken. Ja, aber bevor es reisst, fehlt jetzt noch ein bisschen ab.
Es reisst am...
Aber ich denke mir so, ja, was erwartet ihr denn?
Was erwartet ihr denn? Man soll erwarten, dass das Band reisst?
Was erwartet ihr, wenn ihr einfach von einer tausend Meter hohen Brücke springt?
Also du sagst selber schuld.
Ja, nee, so weit will ich nicht gehen. Ich weiss, du willst mich denunzieren, du willst mich in dieser Richtung, du willst mich hier der Rotkeitschirrkopf. Ich will die Banshee-Leute gegen dich aufbringen, weil das ist eine Bevölkerungsgruppe, mit denen du wirklich nicht scherzen willst. Wenn du die gegen dich aufbrichst, dann hast du echt ein Problem. Du schubst Leute in die Nesseln und sagst, ha ha, guck mal, ist dir gefallen. Ja, ganz genau. Ja, ganz genau. Was er dir mal weiss. Damit du nicht auffällst mit deinen Unzulänglichkeiten. Ja, völlig richtig. Weil ich mir denke, warum läuft der direkt neben den Brennnesseln? Was denkt der denn, was passiert? Das war meine Logik damals. Ah ja ja ja. Das stimmt schon. So, meine Mail, die hier reinkam gerade. Wir lesen die mal vor. Richtig, die Klasse wird es auch interessieren, was du hier für laute Mails kriegst. Weil der das betrefft. Mhm. Wie geht es Ihnen, Herr Tietze? Ja. Weißt du schon, von werefft. Wie geht es Ihnen, Herr Tietze?
Weißt du schon, von wem es ist?
Wie geht es Ihnen, Herr Tietze? Ist das so ein
Google-Microsoft-Ding, Sie haben noch einen Termin?
Nein, die Zeit.
Lieber Herr Tietze, die Temperaturen steigen,
die Natur blüht auf und die Sonne zeigt sich
immer häufiger. Während wir den Frühling
allmählich begrüssen, begleiten uns auch weiterhin
viele bewegende Nachrichten aus aller Welt.
Wir möchten daher von Ihnen erfahren, wie geht es Ihnen zur Umfrage? Wie geht es dir denn? Stefan, wie geht es dir? Ihr könnt eine Umfrage machen. Ich würde mich wirklich interessieren, wie es dir geht. So, ich kann auf drei Smilies klicken. Es ist wie diese Bewertung nach so einem Flughafenklo, weißt du? Ja. Also doll lachend, neutral und traurig. Ich würde neutral klicken. Nur weil es keine fünf gibt, dann wäre ich bei vier. Aber ich bin nicht in Ekstase, ich bin nicht in Hochstimmung, ich bin mir geht es aber auch nicht schlecht, mir geht es gut. Blicken Sie optimistisch, das ist schon die letzte Frage, in die kommenden Monate? ja, nein, ich weiss nicht. Klarer Fall von, weiss ich nicht. Wow, okay, gut, dann haben wir jetzt die Ergebnisse da. Ich finde es toll, mal einen kleinen Einblick wirklich in deine, in dein Leben zu bekommen. Du bist ja hier Medienprofi, du ziehst die Maske an, der Clown, aber schön, dass wir jetzt mal wirklich dir ins Herz schauen konnten. Weißt du, da bin ich mir auch nicht zu schade, dass ich hier ungefiltert immer einen Blick in mein aufregendes Innenleben gebe. Dass du wirklich komplett blank ziehst, dass du wirklich komplett einfach Hose runter, alles runter und wirklich blank ziehst, auch vor der Community, so was preiszugeben, auf die Frage, wie geht es dir, Mittel, Alter, das haut mich um. Ja, nee, so Mittel, also so obages, so ein, ja, ja, ja, ich finde, wir haben heute echt einen Durchbruch gemacht, Stefan. Wir haben uns wirklich mal kennengelernt heute, dass wir wirklich uns mal nicht jetzt als Fake-Ey, wie lange machen wir den Podcast schon? 450 Folgen? Ey, natürlich, Clontin, klar, wenn du mich fragst, wie es mir geht, sage ich, boah. Und das war echt ein Moment, wo ich gemerkt habe, hier sitzt nicht nur einfach ein Co-Moderator neben mir, sondern ein Freund. Ach so. Ich glaube, das geht in eine andere Richtung. Ja gut, ein Freund würde sich an meinen U-Bots sehr erinnern, aber das war sein Nuss. Also das ist natürlich ein Punkt. Moritz, danke für das Intro, vielen, vielen Dank. Die Pan-Flöte, kommt Pan-Flöte von Pan für alles oder kommt es von dem Fabelwesen? Peter. Achso, Peter Pan, ich dachte jetzt an Pan's Labyrinth, ein vielseitiges Wort anscheinend. Pan, ja, ja. Heißt auch Pfanne. Und überspannend. Alles überspannende, Pan, ja, ja, ja. Peter Pan. Peter Pan ist kein Fan von Peter Pan. Captain Hook hat immer, finde ich, ein bisschen überstrahlt. Ich finde, Captain Hook war immer die eigentliche Hauptfigur, wohingegen Peter Pan, ich werde nicht alt, warum bist du dann aber so alt wie du bist und kein Fötus, warum bist du nicht ein Spermium, also warum alterst du auf genau dieses Kinderalter und dann aber nicht weiter, also hast du in dem, ist es wie bei den Vampiren, weil bei. Kann man dich hot finden oder ist es dann. Richtig, du bist jetzt über die Jahre alt, richtig, richtig, also ist ein Kind, eine Erwachsenheit mit einem Kinderkörper, also wie, was sind die Regeln, genau was sind die Regeln? Und ich finde, das hätte man im Film klären müssen. Da hätte es ein paar Texthafeln gebraucht. Ja, oder zumindest, ja, oder einfach mal Dialog sehen, Dialog, Dialog, Dialog sehen. Richtig. Das stört mich ja, dass die dann irgendwie so, ja, wo fahren wir hin, ja, da hin und dann fahren wir hin. Weißt du, dieses Show don't tell, tell, please tell me, tell me, tell me, I don't get it. Please tell me, otherwise I won't get it. Ja, absolut. Und dann ist natürlich die Frage, das ist so wie bei Vampiren, die ja ein normales Leben führen und dann gebissen werden und dann nicht mehr altern. Das heißt, Vampire, die gebissen werden und dann nicht mehr altern. Genau, bei Twilight zum Beispiel ist es ja so. The Twilight Zone. Nein, The Twilight Saga. Bis zum Abendgrauen, bis zur Morgenröte, bis zum Abendgrauen, Eclipse. Bis zum Mittagstee. Finde ich eine der krassen Curveballs der Filmgeschichte. Bis zum Morgengrauen, bis zur Abendsonne, Eclipse. Du hast dieses schlechte Wortspiel etabliert mit Biss, mit Doppelbiss wegen Vampir. Dann macht zumindest Ebiss. Eccbiss, ja genau, sowas. Siehst durch. Und da habe ich mir natürlich immer die Frage gestellt, was ist, wenn so ein Vampir irgendwie so ein ganz junges Baby beißen würde, so ein winziges Babyvampir, das nie wächst, würde das auch intellektuell weiter wachsen und wäre dann so total elaboriert und so, ja gut, also ich wurde mit vier Monaten gebissen. Und seitdem natürlich, guckt natürlich, wo meine Opfer sind. Krabbelgruppe, Kita und so, komme nicht gut rum und da kriegst du auch gutes Babyblut, das ist gut. Inzwischen so nach sechs und acht Jahren bin ich auch sehr gut darin, ein Baby zu imitieren. Und so schaffe ich es dann auch mal nach wie vor, Leute an mich ranzulassen, haben wir in die Krippe. Keine Angst vorm Klischee, sage ich immer. Also man darf sich da nicht verkünsteln, es ist ein harter Knochenjob jeden Tag. So ein Baby hat nicht viel Blut, davon kann ich nicht lange leben, deswegen... Können Sie sich mal ganz kurz runterbeugen? Sie haben da was am Hals. Ah, okay. Was? Sie haben da irgendwas... Ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah dein Kopf 600 Jahre alt ist? Ja, wahrscheinlich schon, weil es nicht körperlich bleibt. Das ist die Frage, die bleibt. Ich glaube, ich würde einfach 25. So was, ne? Ja, ist wahrscheinlich. Körperlich piekt man mit 25. Bei Dr. Kawashimas Hirntraining war immer... Ich kenne ein schön, das heißt Gehirnjogging. Immer falle ich wieder auf rein.
Ich habe vergessen, wie es heißt.
Da war es dann so, dass du dein Ergebnis, du hast ja diesen Test gemacht, Kopf rechnen oder irgendwas merken.
Ich habe alles vergessen. Ich kann mich daran nicht erinnern.
Und dann wurde das Ergebnis immer angegeben in Wie alt ist dein Kopf?
Ich habe das Video, ich habe das gespielt mit 14.
Ja.
Und dann wurde halt so, ja, dein Kopf ist 62.
Und dann die mir schon, ist es gut oder ist es schwächt? Danke oder krieg dich. Das ist ein Wettbewerb, der sich in den Wettbewerb und der Wettbewerb, der sich in den Wettbewerb und der Wagt, was ist mit den Jahren davor? Also wachsen wir rauf, weil ich war 14 und denke mir, okay, ich habe ein Gehirn mit 23, ich jetzt besser als ich sollte oder wo ist die Kurve? Was ist die Kurve? Also ist es ein linearer Zerfall oder ist 62 sogar entspannt, weil es nach 70 rapide runtergeht oder heißt 62, ich weiß viel, aber lerne nicht gut? Das ist die Frage. Würdest du sagen, du bist heute klüger als vor fünf Jahren? Das ist eine Frage, die ich mag, weil ich das Wort klug, muss man sehr genau definieren, weil intelligent, also okay, meinst du gebildet? Schlau, interpretier es, wie du willst, weil ich bin definitiv dümmer als vor fünf Jahren, aber hallo, aber definitiv. Ich schaue manchmal Quizshows an und denke mir, das sollte man definitiv wissen. Das sollte man definitiv wissen. Das hätte ich vor fünf Jahren auch noch gewusst. Hauptstadt von Brasilien, irgendwie sowas. Wo ich mir denke, Rio, da ist keiner irgendwas, was weiß ich, Carlotto, kein Plan. Das hätte ich vor fünf Jahren noch gewusst. Brasil, keine Ahnung, überhaupt keine Ahnung. Ja, das ist dann sowas wie Bildung, genau, da würde ich sagen, da, ja, weiß nicht, ob ich da jemals gut drin war. Da bin ich ja mit meinem Nischeninteresse und dann weise ich in dem Moment dann viel darüber. Aber jetzt mal so klassisch IQ-Test. So Dinge kombinieren, rein vervollständigen, so der Klassiker so. Da bin ich locker 20, 30, weniger als vor fünf Jahren. Jahre alt. Da bin ich wirklich, das Ergebnis so, sie haben sie sie haben sieben Jahre. Du meinst sowas wie, ein Zebra steht zu Kindergärten, wie ein Rhinozeros zu Altenheimen. Genau, sowas in der Richtung. Du hast hundert Schüsseln Cornflakes, du hast aber nur zwei Flaschen Milch. Wie stellst du sicher... Wie stellst du es an? Wie stellst du sicher... Was machst du jetzt? Hä? Nee, was machst du jetzt? Carla, die Mutter von Toni und Babette ist, ist Babette die Tante von Clara. Clara ist Mirkus' Nichte. Wer ist der Vater? Also vier Schüsseln erst mal esse ich direkt. Die kommen erst mal direkt weg. Milch, Vater ist Milch. Und dann schauen wir mal, welche Art von Cornflakes es überhaupt ist. Es gibt ja diese berühmten Harvard-Fragen, wo man so super um die Ecke denken muss.
Da ist ja auch eine, angenommen, du bist so ein Zentimeter gross und du bist in einem Mixer und in einer Minute geht der Mixer an.
Was machst du?
Und da wirst du gespracht in Harvard.
Ja, von mir aus hast du ein Handy.
Das Handy ist aber winzig klein. Das heißt, du bist ganz hoch. Wie würdest du klingen? Wenn du ein Zentimeter groß bist, sind deine Stimmbänder klein und du bist ganz hoch. Hallo, kannst du mir den Mixer aufstellen? Wer spricht da? Entschuldigung, wer spricht da? Stefan! Wer ist da? Stefan, das ist ein bisschen klein. Stefan, das ist ein bisschen klein. Stefan, das ist ein bisschen klein. Was denn? Ich bin ganz klein. Dauert zu lange. Das war keine Minute. Dauert zu lange. Sie haben verlorenen Test, weil es keine Minute sie schätzen können. Nein, da gibt es ein großes Video auf Veritasium, die analysiert haben, weil die richtige Antwort. Sich ducken. Da haben dann Leute gesagt, sich ducken oder kann man an einem Glas hoch. Nee, es gibt keine richtige Antwort, aber es geht darum, wie kreativ deine Antwort ist oder so ein Bullshit. Nee, die Antwort ist, du springst. Du springst einfach raus. Kann man nicht. Kann man, schon. Was für ein Bullshit? Was? Schau dir das Video gerne an, da wird genau das erklärt, weil die können das einfach rauspringen. Dann will ich bei allem Respekt, will mir sowas ohne Respekt, ich will dann, wenn das die Antwort auf die dumme Drecksfrage ist, auf dieser Schule nicht sein. Sie sind eh abgelehnt. Nee, das können sie nicht sagen, nachdem ich gesagt habe, ich will auf der Schule gar nicht sein. Nee, Sie wurden abgelehnt. Ich nehme nicht die Antwort. Nee, aber ich habe mich ja gar nicht mehr beworben. Warum sind Sie denn hier? Warum stehen Sie, Sie stehen im Halteverbot. Ich wollte mich beworben. Sie sind in die Ehrgehechel. Ich wollte mich beworben. Die Krawatte ist jetzt schief. Sie sind in die Ehrgehechel. Ja. Und jetzt sitzen Sie hier, warum denn? Lehnen Sie alle Leute ab mit schiefer Krawatte oder was? Haben Sie da schon gedacht, ah, die lehne ich ab?
Nein, so. Ich wollte mich bewerben, aber dann kam ein dummes Rätsel. Die können mich nicht rausschmeissen, weil ich ja gar nicht hier sein will. Dann gehen Sie doch einfach. Ja, was würden Sie da machen, wenn Sie... Nee, Gegenfrage. Was würden Sie machen, wenn Sie ganz, ganz gross sind, aber ein Meteorit auf die Erde einschlägt? Was würden Sie machen, wenn Sie riesig gross sind wie am Mond? Die Meteoriten auffangen. Schönen Tag noch. Gleichfalls. Aber du kannst tatsächlich rausspringen, weil, und das fand ich auch einen interessanten Fakt, alle Tiere können ungefähr gleich hoch springen. Also ein Eichhörnchen springt ungefähr einen Meter hoch, ein Hund springt auch ungefähr einen Meter hoch, ein Flo springt auch ungefähr einen Meter hoch, ein Pferd springt auch ungefähr einen Meter hoch. So, es ist alles springt gleich hoch. Nein, ich springe gleich durchs Mikro, weil ohne Witz, wenn ein Mensch, ein Mensch sind ja super unathletische Wesen, wenn wir klein wären, können wir nicht hochspringen, können nicht so, können wir nicht als einen Mixer rausspringen. Doch, weil wenn du klein bist, dann ist halt alles krasser. Schon klar. Weil das Gewicht anders skaliert als deine Muskelkraft und so. Aber proportional haben doch Flöhe ganz andere. Diskutiere nicht mit mir, diskutiere mit dem Video, schreibe deinen Messenger. Das Video und schreite mit Veritasium nicht mit mir, ich bin nur der Botschafter. Ich habe nur diese Kiste, mir hat jemand diese Kiste in die Hand. Ich gucke in deine eisklauen Augen. Florentin. Stehen dir meine Augen eigentlich? Nein, nein, nein, die sind super auf meiner... Hör kurz zu, weil ich will nicht Veritasium durch dich jetzt hören, sondern ich möchte Florentins Meinung hören. Lass uns mal ein bisschen was von dir hören. Du hast recht, ja, du hast recht. Ich verstecke mich zu oft unter Internet-Memes und Videos. Menschen auf Flo-Grösse. Der Flo besteht zu fucking 75 Prozent aus seinen Springbeinchen. Der Mensch hat immer noch seine kleinen Arthrose-Knie, seine kleinen Wackler. Würdest du sagen, jetzt ohne dieses scheisse Hintergrundwissen, was du dir angeneigt hast,, wo du wahrscheinlich auch die Hälfte vergessen hast an Informationen, genau, wer springt höher? Ja, der Flo springt wahrscheinlich höher, aber trotzdem springst du hoch genug, um aus dem Mixer rauszupacken. Was hast du für ein Mixer? Das sind ja nur 30 Sekunden. Das sind aber 40 Zentimeter, aber wie gross ist ein Mixer? 30 Zentimeter. Mein Mixer ist riesig zu Hause. Ja, aber du musst ja nur aus dem Gefäss raus. Aber ich kenne ja Ihre amerikanischen Mixer nicht, das ist ja meine Antwort.
Sie stehen jetzt vor dem Fenster. Sie stehen immer noch im Halteverbot.
Ihr Auto wird gerade abgeschleppt. Ihr Auto wird gerade abgeschleppt. Ja, was denn?
Ich weiss ja gar nicht, wie gross Ihre Mixer sind.
Normaler Standard-Mixer, ungefähr so hoch.
Antwort nicht.
So, darum geht es doch.
So, tschüss.
Er will von dir hören, dass du rausspringen kannst, neuer Bewerber. Ach, das geht nicht. Das dürfen wir jetzt echt nicht machen. Ja, ich, ja. Security. Ja, okay, dann sind sie auch raus. Was? Dann sind sie jetzt auch raus. Weil der Typ draußen hat das Fett geklopft und sagt, wir können rausspringen? Ja, dann sind sie jetzt auch raus, Herr Hawkin. Wissen Sie was? Ihm will ich es zeigen. Ich werde einen Nobelpreis verdienen oder so. Ich werde Bücher, mehrere Bücher rausbringen oder so. Oder so. Ja, ich freue mich, von Ihnen zu lesen. Tschüss. Können Sie die Tür aufmachen? Warum? Oder so. Warum? Ich weiss, weil ich glaube, ich jetzt schon nicht mehr alleine diesen Raum verlassen kann. Okay. Danke. So, genau. Und ja, also da müsst ihr aufpassen. Das hätte vielleicht der Stefan von vor fünf Jahren richtig beantwortet. Heute seht ihr dieses Bündel von Hass und Nervosität und Selbstverzweiflung.
Ihr habt das gerade erlebt, was diese Frage mit ihm gemacht hat.
Vor fünf Jahren hätte er, ich überlege mal, wie ist das denn, holt den Bleistift raus, wie skaliert Muskelkraft.
Heute, nein, das konnte nicht wahr sein.
Das ist nochmal ganz anders, du hast dich anders entwickelt. Hast du mal ein E-Cutis gemacht früher? Äh, nein. Ich schon online, weiss ja aber nicht mehr, ob man das erzählen kann, aber es hat so zwei Stunden gedauert. Du hast auch schon den Testmarkt-DNA, oh, hast du das mitbekommen? Ah ja. Auf Reddit, du wurdest gewarnt, führ uns ein. Äh, nee, ich habe das nicht auf Reddit mitbekommen, aber mir haben heute private Leute geschrieben und gesagt, 23andMe steht vor der Insolvenz. Die haben deine DNA analysiert, du hast da in Richtigkeit, 23andMe, den habe ich in Gläschen onaniert und dann habe ich den geschickt. Ja, dann habe ich sie den geschickt, dann haben die gesagt, ne, rein spucken, dann habe ich gesagt, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry. Dann habe ich dann reingespuckt, dann kam raus, ich bin 50% Snickers. Dann habe ich gesagt, again, I'm so sorry, not a Snickers. Not a Snickers, sincerely Stefan, not a Snickers. Also 10% Irland, 40% Portugal, 50% Erdnuss. Okay, da hatte ich mal eine Kurzfilmidee, dass man so einen Gentest abschickt und dann kommt raus, dass man Alien ist oder so.
Oh, finde ich auch gut. Sie haben hier noch so drei Prozent extraterrestrisches Genmaterial.
Was?
Das heisst, ihre Ur-Ur-Ur-Ur-Ur-Oma könnte ein Alien gewesen sein.
Meine Ur-Ur-Ur-Ur-Ur-Oma?
Ja.
Die Betty.
Die Betty. Die Betty.
Die sah auch so ein bisschen merkwürdig aus.
Ja, das kann gut sein.
Ich hatte so riesen Finger und so einen ganz quadratischen Kopf.
Ich sehe hier gerade und es gibt noch einen Verwandten.
Möchten Sie wissen, wo dieser Verwandte wohnt?
Ja, klar.
In Harvard. Ist das der Dekan? Das kann ich Ihnen nicht sagen. Ich bin ein sehr guter, sehr guter, sehr guter, sehr guter, sehr guter, sehr guter, sehr guter, sehr guter, sehr guter, sehr gut Sie, würden Sie sagen, man kann, wenn man ganz, ganz klein ist, aus einem Mixer springen? Auf gar keinen Fall.
Das habe ich auch gedacht.
Danke, schönen Tag.
Schönen Tag noch.
Und dann flog ich hin und habe dem Alien aufs Maul gehauen.
Kam raus, kam nämlich dann raus, dass der Dekan, bei dem ich das Bewerbungsgespräch hatte, ein Alien ist und diese Frage mit seinem Alienwissen richtig stimmt, weil die können hochspringen. Wäre der aufgestanden, hätte man gesehen, der hat vier Meter lange Beine. Okay, verstehe. Ich habe mich nämlich hinter der Hecke versteckt und habe gesehen, wie er nach Hause gesprungen ist. Okay, alles klar. Und das ist eine Kurzfilmeidee, oder was? Weil ich finde die eigentlich ganz gut. Und jetzt ist Folgendes passiert. Du hast deine DNA in fremde Hände gegeben gegen einen Obolus,
du hast Geld gezahlt und deine DNA hergegeben.
Also diese Firma wurde auch schon neunmal gehackt.
Ich habe eure Nachrichten gelesen,
vielen Dank. Das ist ein großes Problem.
Es wurden auch schon, glaube ich,
Mörder oder so geschnappt oder so Täter,
weil, und das ist ganz spannend,
ich bin ein großer Fan von
der HBO-Serie mit dem Namen Riesenfans. Riesengrossen Fans. Schau das einmal pro Monat. Von I'll Be Gone in the Dark. Sehr gut. Meine Güte, ich bin mich froh für dich, dass das jetzt noch geklappt hat. Und zwar ist dieamara, der, ähm, leider verstorbenen Frau von Patton Oswalt, den wir ja kennen, äh, von Spence, King of Queens. Ah, ah, okay. Und sie ist eine ganz tolle Journalistin und hat, äh, zu dem Original Night Stalker recherchiert. Ja. Das ist eine ganz, ganz tolle Dokumentation, die könnt ihr wirklich auf HBO gucken, also guckt da mal, wie ein V-B-E-N- Ja, so gut, wie die nicht reinkommt. Ja, ja, ja, ein bisschen problematisch. Aber die ist ganz fantastisch. Es gibt auch ein tolles Buch, das könnt ihr einfach kaufen. Und sie hat dann am Ende, glaube ich, also auch unter anderem mit Gentechnik, die dann so langsam aufkam und DNA-Proben, die man noch von Tatort damals gesammelt hatte, hat man das dann eingeschickt. Und dann wurde dir aber kein Name genannt von dem Täter, weil das dürfen die nicht rausgeben, sondern die Verwandten. Oh, okay. Also so grob, das ist dann natürlich ein super scary Moment gewesen, weil man so wusste, man hatte plötzlich dann so Leute. Ja, aber ich denke mir, frag irgendeinen von diesen Verwandten, die werden es wissen, wer der Nightstalker-Mörder ist, oder? Ja. Stellt euch mal vor, eine Journalistin steht vor eurer Tür und fragt euch, irgendjemand aus eurer Verwandtschaft ist ein Serienmörder. Jeder hat einen Namen. Ach so, Verwandtschaft. Jeder hat einen Namen im Kopf, jeder. Und den könnt ihr jetzt gerne der Kriminalpolizei schicken und dann werden wir schon weiter. Du mit deinem Denunzieren heute, du bist ja rumdenunzieren. Ich habe Bock zu denunzieren einfach, aber ich habe eine gute Idee gehabt für ein Verbrechen, weil du gerade von Verbrechern redest, weil Verbrechen ist ja ein Problem, weil es gibt ja Gesetze. Das war Schritt eins meiner Überlegung. Gesetz abschaffen. Nee, geh in ein Gebiet, wo die Gesetze einfach nicht so harsch sind, und zwar ins Bereich Tiere. Tiere sind Objekte, das heißt, wenn nun Hund, also angenommen, du gehst in den Park und du trittst einen Hund tot, da ist ein Mensch, der läuft mit seinem geliebten Hint und du gehst hin und du trittst ihn einfach tot, es ist Sachbeschädigung und du zahlst vielleicht ein paar hundert Euro Ersatz. Das war's. Es ist einfach nur ein Objekt. You're talking facts right now?
Ja, einfach nur ein Objekt.
Es ist kein Lebewesen oder so,
es ist halt einfach ein Objekt. You're talking facts right now? Ja, einfach nur ein Objekt.
Es ist kein Lebewesen oder so.
Es ist halt einfach dann kaputt gegangen, als hättest du ein Auto beschädigt.
Glaub ich nicht, wie es funktioniert.
Ja, vielleicht, ich weiss es auch nicht mehr prozentlich.
Und jetzt dachte ich mir, das perfekte Verbrechen ist doch Hunde entführen.
Du entführst einen Hund und dann Lösegeld.
Weil strafrechtlich ist das ja einfach nur Diebstahl. Tja, du darfst das Tier nicht quälen. Und Erpressung. Erpressung? Wenn ich doch ein Auto klaue. Nach der Logik könntest du auch sagen, wenn du mir nicht fünf Millionen Euro gibst, werde ich deine Tochter umbringen. Du hast dich ja nach der Logik, nach deiner Logik dann auch nicht strafbar gemacht, weil du ja die Tochter nicht angerührt hast. Aber ist Erpressung so schlimm? Also angenommen, ich klaue dein Auto und ich sage dir, hey, überweis mir hunderttausend Euro und dann kriegst du dein Auto wieder. Wo ist die Straftat? Weil ich habe, ja klar, Diebstahl da, ich habe dann alle Autodiebstahl, richtig. Aber so, ist nicht so wild. Grand Theft.
So ein Grand Theft.
Grand Theft. Okay, Grand Theft. Was heißt schon, Grand? Und da dachte ich mir, das ist noch eine gute Idee, weil die Leute wollen auf jeden Fall den Hund wieder zurückhaben. Ich fütter den gut, ich habe Futter zu Hause und dann zack, löse Geld und dann lässt du den irgendwo los. Und dann sagst du, okay, sobald ich das Geld habe, in Bitcoin irgendwie super sicher, setze ich den Hund aus an einem Ort, den ich dann erst sage, damit die Polizei dann nicht auf mich warten kann. Ja, mir gefällt nicht, wie doll du das durchgedacht hast. Jetzt am Potsdamer Platz habe ich den Hund ausgesetzt, tschau. Und dann muss die Person halt schnell hinfahren und dann schreien wir der Polizei und dann holen die den Hund. Runde Hund und dann ist seinen Kopf abgetrennt und gehäutet. Nein, nein, nein, das ist jetzt Verleumdung. Und da klage ich dich jetzt an. Du hast, Matt, du machst mein Geschäftsmodell. Du bist nicht in der Position, mich zu verleumden. Doch, absolut. Wenn du deinen Hund wieder sehen willst, dann ziehst du die Klage zurück. Also nur mal für alle Anwälte da draußen, prüft das mal. Ich mach das ja, ich bin ja wie in der Hörerschaft. Ich würde nur sagen, dass wir als Hörerschaft und ich jetzt, verschammelt mit der Hörerschaft, machen uns Gedanken um dich, dass du diese Szenarien dann auch so weit zu Ende denkst.
Es gibt ja die guten Hacker und die bösen Hacker. Die guten Hacker versuchen sich irgendwo reinzuhacken und verkaufen dann das Wissen an die Firma im Sinne von, ey Leute, passt auf, ihr habt ihr eine Sicherheitswirkung. Du willst sagen, du spielst das Gedankenspiel durch und stand jetzt free. Um nämlich vorzugreifen, weil wenn nämlich mal der grosse Hundeinführer in Neukölln auftaucht, dann sagen alle, oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott, warum hat die Jurisprudenz dann nicht die Finger gehauen.
Aber das Fahndungszeichnung sieht genauso aus wie du. Ja, die Augen? Ganz andere Augen. Wir haben eine komplett andere Nasenpartie. Vor allem Bart aber. Ganz im Ernst, würdest du irgendeinen Menschen, den du sogar sehr, sehr gut kennst und mehrere tausend Mal gesehen hast, so gut beschreiben können, dass man ein Fahndungszeichen davon machen will, ein Phantombild? Auf gar keinen Fall. Auf gar keinen Fall. Ich glaube auch, never, von Leuten, die ich Millionen Mal gesehen habe, würde ich nichts nicht können.
Grosse Augen, weiß ich nicht.
Ich denke mir so, ist es nicht schlauer
zu sagen, ah, der sah so aus wie Jack Gyllenhaal?
Soft Summer übrigens.
Jack Gyllenhaal
ist ein Soft Summer.
Nice, sehr schön. Rihanna,
Jack Gyllenhaal
und Stefan Tietze. Jennifer Aniston,
Jennifer Aniston, Mark Ruffalo, Mark Ruffalo, Ashton Kutcher. Ashton Kutcher. Gute Truppe. Und ich glaube, so ist es einfacher, einfach zu sagen, sieht aus wie Jake Gyllenhaal. Und dann gibst du halt die Fahndung raus, okay, wir suchen einen Mann, der sieht aus wie Jake Gyllenhaal. Und dann wird halt leider jedes Mal Jake Gyllenhaal verhaftet, der gerade in Köln ist für eine Filmpremiere. Und du so erzielt da sein. Ich kann es nicht ausschliessen. In Prisoners war der schon echt fies. Nee, der war, glaube ich, der Ermittler. In diesem Rätselfilm, wie hieß der nochmal, Enigma? Nee, Zodiac, da war der Ermittler. Ja, aber in Prisoners war er der? Da war er auch der Polizist. Was? Paul Dano war da der Bösewicht. Naja, weiss man nicht, bis zum Ende nicht so ganz. Aber am Ende weiss man es. Weiss ich nicht mehr. Also ja, vielleicht weiss man es. Ich finde es recht ganz ans Ende. Ja, ich erinnere mich einfach nicht mehr ans Ende, weil ich Dr. Kawasaki's Gehirn, Dr. Kawasaki ist Gehirn, was auch immer. Ja, interessant, finde ich interessant. Chilhale. Chilhale. Chilhale. Skarsgar. Ja, ist auch wie Willem Dafoe, der Dafoe heisst. Oder auch nicht hin und her. Ja, und Cristiano Ronaldo heißt eigentlich Shijiano Rinalu.
Rinalu.
Und deswegen sage ich, nee, ich bleibe einfach
bei meiner Aussprache. Ich meine, du weisst es ja,
wie es ist, international wirst du einfach Steve Titz
genannt und musst natürlich gucken, wie du da
Steve Big Titz
und musst dann einfach gucken, wie du damit umgehst.
Das ist mein Nachname, das macht mir
wirklich Kopfzerbrechen, was meine
internationale Karriere planen. Lass uns drüber reden, ich habe ein paar
Vorschläge. Bei Will auch
weird. Naja, Will?
Ich denke immer an Tod,
Ableben, Testament.
Ja, bei mir ist das Problem, glaube ich, eher der Vorname.
Ich glaube, damit kommt der Ami, ist so gut
klar. Florentin, Florentin.
Connected to the iPhone Florentin.
Florentin. iPhone, Florentin
Will. Florentin Will iPhone Florentine well.
Florentine well.
So sagt es zumindest immer mein Bluetooth-Kopfhörer.
Titsi bei mir.
Stefan Titsi.
Ich finde Titsi ganz süss eigentlich.
Itzy Bitsi Titsi.
Du weisst dann... So eine witzige Strip-Lokal irgendwie.
Du weisst dann, dass du einen scheiss Nachnamen hast, wenn du das bei manchen Videospielen
nicht eingeben kannst, weil es, weil das Programm denkt, das ist ein versautes Vulgär-Wort. Aber was sind Möglichkeiten für Künstlernamen? Weil ich glaube, aktuell ist deine Karriere noch erfolglos. Bei Google steht, ich bin bekannt aufs Übnamen des Chats. Gut, das war der Durchbruch. Aber ich glaube, bevor du so richtig abhebst, hast du jetzt noch die Chance, einen Künstlernamen zu etablieren. Weil für viele ist es zu spät. Für viele ist es einfach zu spät. Shakira kann jetzt nicht sagen, oh fuck, ich will doch anders heißen. Was mir gefällt an meinem Vornamen ist Stefan. Da bin ich ja erst skeptisch gewesen, als ich auch zum ersten Mal in den Staaten war, dass mein Vorname da weird zu Steven gemacht wird oder Stefan mit P-H-E-N und so'n Scheiß, bis ich irgendwann dann bei Starbucks herausgefunden habe, was ich sagen muss, damit sie mich wirklich first try richtig schreiben, Stefan. Stefan. Stefan. Stefan. Stefan. Ich sag übrigens bei Starbucks auch immer Stefan.
Ich sag immer Stefan.
Stefan eben nicht.
Stefan schreiben die S-T-E-P-H-E-N.
Und dann sag ich Stefan.
So.
Stefan.
Stefan und die checken das.
Und es ist S-T-E-F-E-N.
Stefan hat was Europäisches, hat was Cooles.
Und dann vielleicht so was unverfänglich wirst wie Stefan Parapopoulos. Unverfänglich? Ja,fänglich wie Stefan Parapopoulos unverfänglich? du bist halt einfach Stefan Parapopoulos super kompliziert zu schreiben ich glaube es klingt gut, man erinnert sich an dich es ist halt natürlich regional jetzt einen relativ klaren Klang Paparadopoulos Papara Paparadopoulos Stefan Paparadopoulos
aber das ist erstmal ein Name
Stefan Paparadopoulos
so, jetzt noch eine selber dazu gekommen
aber wenn du den Namen hörst, denkst du dir, holy shit, der muss gute Filme machen
ich halt so arzi-fazi-Vibe
so ein bisschen okay
düster, schwarz-weiss
ich denke mir, Leute krabbeln an der Decke rum ja, Pool, ja. Auch nicht schlecht, du klingst so wie ein anderer Regisseur. Du hattest Stefan Spiesberg. Spiesberg. Stefan Spiesberg. Stefan Spiesberg. Und dann kommst du so rau und bist so ein knackiger 28-Jähriger und alle so, that guy, he did E.T.? Oh my God.
Titz man. Oh my God, he must have been like eight.
Also ich finde ja, man darf nicht ganz verleugnen, wo mein Name herkommt.
Nee, das finde ich auch. Dein Wurzeln treuen.
Paparadarubtos finde ich ist schwierig.
Wir haben es mal auf dem Tisch.
Es liegt nicht mehr auf deiner Tischhälfte. Es ist runtergefallen, es ist auf dem Weg runtergefallen.
Ich habe ihn lineal genommen und die Tischgrenze abgefahren.
Dabei hast du es runtergeschmissen, ich kann es jederzeit wieder aufheälfte, auf deine Tischhälfte geschoben. Es ist runtergefallen, es ist auf dem Weg runtergefallen. Ich habe ein Lineal genommen und die Tischgrenze abgefahren.
Dabei hast du es runtergeschmissen, ich kann es jederzeit wieder aufheben und wieder auf den Tisch legen.
Deinen Tisch, ja.
Ich bin dafür, dass mein, dass diese Anfangsbuchstabe oder irgendwie so grob so das Gefühl erhalten bleibt.
Ja, das Problem ist bei dir, es ist halt mit TIT relativ schnell aus.
Genau, TIT ist das Problem. Das ZE ist nicht das Problem. Nee. Vielleicht sowas wie Was wären andere coole Silben? Statt Titt, Fott zum Beispiel. Fott, ja. Oder Ja, oder Cot. Cot, Grüt sind alles starke Namen. Oder Att. Ja.
Stefan Atze.
Etzi, Ötzi, Stefan Ötzi.
Du hast natürlich dann irgendwo so ein Schlager.
Vor allem wenn ich vom Leitzfahrer wäre, würde er einfach Titt stehen.
Und alle so.
Aber jetzt habe ich jetzt die neuen Formel, die Rookies, die Youngstars, die neuen Leute, die hier zugekommen sind.
Und einer heisst ja, ich weiss nicht, wie er heisst, Doohan oder so. Ja, Jack Doohan. Ja, aber jetzt heisst, bei ihm steht Do. Ja, auch nicht schlecht. Do, Tit, Poo und Fat. Tit, Fiff, Fuck. Okay. Fuck, Dick und Tit. Aber ich meine, Regisseure haben relativ opulente Namen. Quentin Tarantino. Aber ich finde Stefan Tizzi. Jorgos Latimos. Stefan Tizzi ist einfach ein bisschen zu klein. Das klingt wie so eine kleine Maus aus so einer Kinderei. Ja, genau meine Fähne. Film Stefan Tizzi ans Ziel. Genau wie meine Filmchen. Kleine Filmchen, kleine Name. Ja, wie deine kleinen witzigen Knuddelfilmchen. Ach, ja, problematisch, ne? Aber du hast doch noch einen, du hast doch einen Zweitnamen, Michael. Na, Michael. Könnte man nicht Stephen Michael nennen? Oh ja, dann kriegst du George Michael-Vibes. Dann Steve George. Ja? Steve George Michael. Ja, mir gefällt die Richtung. Steve George? Ja. Oder halt, ich meine, du willst ja aussagen, dass du einen Beruf hast, Du engagierst ja keine Leute, die noch nie gearbeitet haben. Deswegen könntest du sagen zum Beispiel sowas wie Steve Jobs. Wo du einfach sagst, du hast einen Job. Ich hatte schon viele Jobs. Ich hatte schon viele Jobs. I've been through a lot. Steve, I've been through a lot. Jobs. Jobs. Ja, finde ich gut. Ich finde, da ist Potenzial da auf jeden Fall.
Ich finde, du solltest als nahestehende, unverwandte, uneingenommene Person würde ich dir raten, den Namen zu erinnern.
Okay, ich nehme es mal mit.
Es gibt keinen Regisseur mit einem uncoolen Namen. Denk da mal drüber nach.
Nolan?
Nolan ist cool, ne?
Nolan ist richtig cool. Cameron, Coppola, Brady Corbe. Richtig coole Namen. Corbe. Machst du einfach. Französisch hilft halt auch, ne? Hilft richtig gut. Tizze. Stefan Tizze. Tizipas. Zieht ja den Tennisspieler Stephanus Tizipas. Sehr gut. Der ist sehr nah dran. Das ist wirklich, aber habt ihr da mal einen Gentest gemacht? Nimm mal deine 23 in meet Gentest und geh zu Stephan Tizipas. Danke, dass wir da wieder sind. Und dass ihr da mal wieder zusammenkommt. Genau, wir können das nämlich nicht mehr und daraufhin wollte ich hinaus, denn ich habe meine Daten jetzt gelöscht. Weil jetzt, es wurde schon wirklich, ich habe das Röhrchen gespuckt, die haben ja DNA, die haben mir gesagt, woher ich komme. Und das war spannend. Ich habe ein paar Verwandte kennengelernt in Milwaukee, die dann auch mich eingeladen haben zum grossen Familientreffen. Ich bin Viertel Roszinski. Auch da ist es spannend. Wow! Muss man mal ergründen. Hast du nie erzählt, dass das rauskam? Das macht aber, sage ich mal, eine Nacht im Juli genetisch heikel. Genau, da können wir jetzt nicht reingehen, weil dann würde ich nicht aufpassen. So, und dann, genau, haben die jetzt alle Daten von mir? Okay, ich versuche es nochmal. Die haben alle Daten von mir. Alle Daten! Die sind jetzt auch schon futsch. Alle Daten wurden gehackt. Die wurden ein paar Mal gehackt, das war ein Problem. So, und jetzt habe ich heute erfahren, dass die Firma voll ins Pleite ist, vielleicht aufgekauft wird, es ist auf jeden Fall nicht abzusehen, in welche Hände das fällt. Oh Gott, wer will man, dass diese Firma kauft, oder? Wenn das jetzt Google oder Amazon kauft oder so, dann ist wirklich Dystopie direkt da. Dr. Blofeld, Blofeld, oder irgendwie sowas. Irgendwer hat das jetzt gekauft, jedenfalls. Dr. Octopus, irgendwie sowas in der Ecke. Dr. Ock. Aber der scheint ein seriöser Typ zu sein. Leck, der Leckter, Lex Luthor, irgendwie so. Ja, das ist echt auch irgendwie Sauron, der Zerstörer, irgendwie sowas in der Ecke. Ja, Sauron der Zerstörer war es, glaube ich. War ja so ein Dreier, also weiß ich es auch nicht mehr, Vader. Naja, und dann habe ich jetzt überlegt, vielleicht sind meine Daten nicht mehr der sicher. Und dann konnte man tatsächlich alles zerstören lassen. Also du hast den Selbstzerstörungsknopf gedrückt, bevor die in falsche Hände geraten, hast du sie zerstören lassen. Ja. Du hast deine Daten aber noch, du hast die Ergebnisse noch. Genau, die habe ich mir als TXT heruntergeladen, die habe ich jetzt noch auf meinem Desktop. Und da stand ja auch drin, dass du immun gegen Aids bist, ne? Ja. Du bist einer der wenigen Menschen, die immun gegen Aids sind, deswegen flagst du dich reichlich vor. Einer in Tausend ist immun gegen Aids. Ja, also das Podcast-Ufo war lange dabei, er hat das begleitet, das ist nicht mehr da. Kann ich niemandem mehr raten. Also wenn ihr bei 23andMe damals auch vielleicht durch mich angefangen habt, eure Daten, also DNA dazu untersuchen zu lassen, dann jetzt gibt es eine Internetanleitung, die ihr findet. Ich frag mich natürlich, wann jetzt diese Farbtests gehackt werden und dann die bankrott gehen und die verkauft werden und du in einem Jahr wieder hier sitzt. Reist du Firmen in den Untergrund? Das ist problematischer, wenn dann die Hacker, wenn die Vaders der Welt sehen, ah, er trägt etwas, in dem er total blass aussieht. Loser! Das wäre nicht was noch schlimmer. Sind wir ein schlechter Einfluss? Nee, wir sind Königsmacher. Nee, ich habe eher das Gefühl, wir sind Tyrannmacher und die dann irgendwann stürzen. Wir sind Botenmacher. Wir sind wie so eine Auszeichnung fürs Lebenswerk und danach sterben sie. Ich habe wirklich das Gefühl, wir haben so einen Anti-Midas-Effekt, dass die Dinge kaputt gehen, die wir anfassen. Was? Midas, der hat, wurde ja alles zu Gold, was er angefasst hat. König Midas. Und dann bei uns ist es das Gegenteil. Guck mal, du weißt doch noch mehr als früher. Ja gut, ja du hast recht. Vielleicht bin ich extrem schlau. Habe ich letztens eine Folge Only Connect wieder gesehen? Ja, ich auch, ich lieb's. Man kriegt vier Begriffe nacheinander und man muss so früh wie es geht sagen, was die Begriffe verbindet. Und der erste Begriff war General Grievous. Und ich dachte mir, let's go! Endlich kann ich den ganzen Eierköpfen-Brillenträgern da mal sagen, was los ist, Captain General Grievous. Und es war aber in der zweiten Runde, wo man die Sequenz fortsetzen muss. Ja, Sequenz, bin gespannt. Also irgendwie Typ, der 1901 gestorben ist, Typ, der 1902 gestorben ist, Typ, der 1903 gestorben ist. Und dann musst du den vierten Begriff sagen. Also dachte ich mir, okay, General Grievous ist die erste Person der vierteiligen Reihe, was könnte der vierte sein? General Grievous, der Bösewicht in Episode drei, vier, fünf, sechs. Ich bin bei Anzahl Lichtschwerter. Anzahl Lichtschwerter. General Grievous hat vier. Er hat auch drei. Also er kämpft mit Anzahl Lichtschwertern. Er kämpft auch mit drei, weil ihm eins abgeschlagen wird. Aber wer kämpft mit drei Lichtschwertern, mit zwei Lichtschwertern und ein Lichtschwerter wäre ja fast jeder, oder? Genau, every other Jedi. Du kannst dann einfach sagen, wie Kit Fisto, kannst du irgendwie sagen.
Es wäre schon eine Only Connect-Antwort.
Jedi Grievous, Jedi Grievous, Darth Maul, everybody else.
Ja, da dachte ich mir, okay, das hast du jetzt genäht.
Was war die zweite?
Ich weiss es leider nicht mehr, aber... Okay, was ganz anderes also.
Am Ende ging es um die Anzahl der Räder seines Gefährts. Nein. Eins. General Grievous hat so ein Monowheel, so ein Einrad. Stimmt. Und dann irgendwas mit zwei Rädern, irgendwas mit drei Rädern und dann das vierte war irgendwas mit vier Rädern. Und ich habe wirklich an alles gedacht. Ich dachte, okay, der hustet, die Anzahl Lichtschwerter, der hat irgendwie inneren Organe, sind noch verbrannt, irgendwie stirbt durch Laser. Aber ich habe nicht an die Anzahl der Räder seines Drecksgefährtes, das man einmal in einer fucking Szene kurz sieht, habe ich nicht daran gedacht. Da dachte ich mir, okay, wenn du nicht mal die General Grievous-Frage beantwortest, dann bist du raus. Ich habe sogar mal den Sprecher getroffen auf der Star-Celebration.
Der war nett. Richtig netter Kerl. Und der muss halt, hat der auch Götter? Der ist bei ILM Sound Guy, Sound Mechanic Guy. Und der hat, den habe ich dann auch noch kurz getroffen. Er ist der andere, das ist rechst. Aber wir sind sehr ähnlich, spricht er auch. Und der hat da noch damals den The Last Jedi Trailer eine Nacht vorher noch geschnitten, der war sehr nervös und sehr müde. Aber ging ja alles gut aus, würde ich sagen. Das ging ja wirklich unproblem aus, criggly und fanmässig acclaimed. Gut, damit schicken wir euch in ein wohlverdientes Wochenende, ihr Lieben. Geht mal raus, geht in den Sommer, lasst euch braun brachen. Geht mal raus und ich sag euch also auch, geht mal rein.
Geht mal rein, lasst eure Farbtests machen, löscht eure DNA, also wir haben ganz schön viel zu tun.
Erstens, löscht eure DNA-Tests, macht einen Farbtest, geht zum O-Blätter in München,
brecht euch da nicht das Genick, viel Spaß beim Rutschen, bis nächste Woche, tschüss. Macht zu, tschau.
Macht zu, tschau. Nächste Woche. Mach's gut, ciao. Mach's gut, ciao.
It's a worse bird production.